a former high school basketball star is
accused of driving while high
and killing another driver now the
victim's widow says
justice is not being served with the way
the criminal case has been playing out
so far
the i-team's vanessa murphy has more
from the regional justice center
i pray to god that the drawer has seen
the reckless act that he committed
anne-marie eschevoria showed up to court
in a t-shirt honoring her late husband
eric
to see the 19-year-old man accused of
killing him on december 30th
zayon collins is a former bishop gorman
star
athlete i want him to see me i want him
to know that i am present
but she quickly learned thursday morning
she missed his brief moment
in court nobody let me know that this
court
case was going to be held early and i
really wanted to be there
and i'm beyond upset to go in and find
out that it was already done
attorney david chesnov who represents
collins tells the i-team he filed a
motion with a 7 30 a.m
start time according to the las vegas
justice court website
a preliminary hearing which never
happened was set to start at 8.
judge susan balcom called the case
before that ashaveria says the confusion
is
another failure by the justice system
she's upset
collins is not in jail he's on high
level
electronic monitoring my son is 14
and zion is home with his mommy and his
daddy and my son
lost his dad the district attorney
charged collins with dui resulting in
death and reckless driving
when the case was presented to a grand
jury he was not indicted on the dui
charge attorneys for collins argue the
case should be dismissed
metro investigators say collins showed
signs of being high
and he had thc in his system but a
forensic toxicologist told the grand
jury
it is unclear whether the amount shows
he smoked marijuana right before the
crash
the defense team for collins points to
the nevada legislature
currently examining laws about marijuana
use and driving
in a motion they also claimed the crash
was eshevaria's fault
police say collins was speeding at 88
miles per hour while the speed limit was
35.
this is not this poor little 19 year old
boy that plays basketball and he's so
sorry no i'm sorry i'm sorry that you're
an idiot and you did this
the next court date for collins is set
for july 15th
reporting from downtown las vegas
vanessa murphy 8 news now